[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar solutions for dendritic cell
research
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by milteni biotech
to learn more visit miltennybiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
our speaker will answer questions via
the email address you provided during
registration
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr nizar youssef global product manager
immunology immuno oncology milteni
biotech
dr youssef you may now begin your
presentation
welcome everybody to our webinar then
for excel research solutions
in this webinar you will learn about
milton's tools and methods for studying
these subpopulations in human and mouse
here's the agenda for today's webinar
first we will have a brief introduction
then i will talk about sample
preparation for dendritic cell analysis
afterwards i will talk about our flow
cytometric analysis solutions for
human and mouse disease followed by
magnetic isolation of theses and more dc
generation solutions
and at the end i will tease you with our
spatial biology platform for dc
characterization
now the introduction
dendritic cells were discovered by paul
langerhans in 1868 and their function
was described by ralph steinmann in
1973 so these cells are professional
antigen presenting cells that on one
hand promote immunity to foreign
antigens and on the other hand
are capable of inducing tolerance to
self-antigens
dendritic cells can regulate the immune
response by secreting pro and
anti-inflammatories you know cytokines
yeah and these cells come all come in
different flavors and can be
differentiated based on different
factors including the expression uh
of cell surfer markers yeah tissue
localization ontogeny and their
functional specialization
this is a simplified overview of
dendritic cell subsets
in human and mouse
human and mouse and three major dc
substances can be found myeloid
conventional dc1
cdc1 myeloid conventional dc2 cdc2 and
plasmacytoid
dc p dc
and here you see the monocyte drive
disease which do not share ontogeny with
yeah with conventional disease and can
be derived from monocyte lineage during
infection and inflammation so and due to
time reasons i will mainly be discussing
the cc dc subsets listed listed here
yeah however for learning
more about further this is success i
encourage you you know to have a look at
the publication you know listed here
on this slide and further recent you
know uh related you know topic related
publications
as mentioned this is our specialized
antigen presenting cells and have
essential roles
in initiating and regulating innate
unadaptive immune responses
however these cells are basically
different in many ways
here i will focus on key features of
human
disease
so this is have different phenotypical
features they express various type of
markers that can be used to identify
identify these cells
yeah among the most commonly used
markers cd 140 41
is mentioned for cd1
cdc1 and
cdc1c
you know
is expressed in cdc2 and markers like cd
123
cd 303
and cd 304
are you know commonly expressed in p
dc's
yeah so these substances have different
ontogeny i depend on different growth
factors
yeah so there their
identity is regulated via the expression
of different transcription factors
and function specialization of dc
subsystem results from different
from you know from the expression of
receptors you know different receptors
including you know the pattern
recognition receptors yeah such as prrs
yeah but also but also various cytokines
uh secretion
yeah so it's commonly known that cdc1
are potent induces of
of th
you know helper t style one immunity and
cdc 2 can induce
th1 th2 as well as th17
and
pdcs uh you know initiate antiviral uh
responses
so
so to learn more about human and mouse
subsets i recommend you treat the
excellent review by stephanie buckley
yeah this is you know this paper is is
published in nature review uh in
immunology yeah so i recommend you to
read it for further information about
human and mouse
disease
next i will talk about sample
preparation for the traditional analysis
sample preparation for dc analysis can
be challenging
why
because we have many tissue sources and
there are different protocols available
you know which can be overwhelming to
select the right one so researchers
working with human disease
most commonly
use blood and blood products such as
buffy code lrc's and like leukopaks
here sample preparation
for analysis
is easy and researchers can
often perform density gradient
centrifugation or rbst lysis
human bone motor samples are usually you
know purified by
density gradient centrifugation
and rbc lysis whereas in mice
researchers usually use
fumers and tibias
and flush the bone marrow with medium or
buffer
so the analysis of tissue residue
infiltrating disease is most complicated
due to tissue-specific enzymatic
digestion and dissociation protocols
our
sample preparation solution for milt
antibiotic that can
you know make your life easier here are
the gentile max
tissue dissociators yeah and the genital
max tubes and tissue dissociation kits
so to simplify you know the you know the
labor intensive process of preparing
single cell suspension for dc analysis
yeah so using this
technology you know viability epitope
preservation reproducibility and speed
are guaranteed
this is an exemplary analysis of mouse
dc subsets after gentlemax dissociation
gentle max dissociation
of spleen
lung and lamina propria
so enzymatic tissue dissociation with
the gentile max is a gentle method to
obtain a suspension of single cells for
further down extreme
analysis yeah so the enzymes including
at milton is you know kid are highly
purified to maximize epitope
preservation
the enzymatic digestion and tissue
specific mechanical dissociation
parameters are optimized to ensure
high cell viability you know a lot to
look consistent in you know enzymatic
activities and and automation and
standardization you know ensure
high
reproducibility
so are well set
here
now let's move to the next part flow
cytometric analysis of human and mouse
disease
flowchart geometry is one of the main
and essential tools for studying
dendritic cells
so if you're trying to accurately
analyze cells by flow cytometry the most
reliable solution we can offer you is
our re-affinity antibodies yeah these
are recombinantly engineered antibodies
yeah in which the fc
region has been mutated to minimize
background signallium so if we translate
this to the myeloid cell you know
language yeah and we know that dendritic
cells belong to the myeloid cell family
yeah the fc blocking step is not
required
anymore yeah so the real affinity
antibodies show high you know epitope
uh a specific specificity you know and
low low background binding yeah and oh
so
and all the affinity antibodies you know
are igg one isotype you know yeah igg
one isotype so making
you know
yeah the isotype control is staining
easy yeah so the reaffinity antibody
ensure you know
you consistent and reproducible
reproducible results you know so you
don't need to worry about you know about
consistency you know and reproducibility
you know of your of your experiments
in this table you know is an optimized
panel of for analysis of spilling
disease using max quant or similar
flow cytometric analyzer
so the getting a strategy starts with
the selection
of cells and the exclusion of debris
using side and forward scatter
yeah
and and and next you know you select
singlets and live cells where viability
dies such as pi or 7ad can be
used and whenever is possible
so we recommend the macrophysics
exclusion yeah using for example the
markers f4 80 and
cd64 is staining yeah and then and
finally we can analyze their abundance
of the three major dc subsets you know
in the mouse's plane
so the conventional dc's
show high level of cdc you know cd11c
and mhc class 2
expression
and can be divided into two you know
major you know subsets yeah this is uh
uh xcr1 expressing cdc1 and srip you
know uh
or you know cd11b expressing uh cdc
cdc2
yeah so the plasmacytoids plasmacytoid
dcs usually express you know
intermediate level of cd11c
uh that's
single
you know
cyclic cyclic edge and pdcl pdcl1
staining is recommended you know to
facilitate more you know uh precise
gating
this is similar to the spilling dc
characterization approach i described on
the previous slide
after dissociation mouse spleen cells
were stained with the antibodies
described here in this panel yeah and
after exclusion of their cells debris
and doublets yeah so cd11 c positive and
mst mhc class class two positive
conventional dc's were selected and
further subdivided into
xcr1 yeah and cd 172
yeah or cd11b you know positive uh
subsets
and the plasma cytodisease
plasmocytoid dcs can be easily
identified by
uh cyclic edge
yeah
and
pdca1 expression
so
yeah you can find detailed standing
protocol
under the link provided here yeah on our
website so multibiotech website you just
when you get the pdf of this uh
powerpoint yeah you can
you know you can click here yeah under
hyperlink which will bring you directly
to the detailed protocol on our website
in the previous slides i talked about
the analysis of mouse dc
now
to analyze the abundance of the main
three
dc subsets in in human blood we have
developed a staining panel and getting a
strategy
in collaboration
uh with yolanda de frise from the
university of nijmegen yeah so after
selecting
you know viable and and cd45 positive
cells and the execution of cd20 positive
yeah this is the b cells and and cd14
positive monocytes yeah the three dc
substances can be identified where cross
presenting cdc one coexispress you know
these sparkers yeah and cdc2 express
these two markers and plasmacytoids you
know this is expressed you know these
two you know markers yeah and this is
actually what you see here you know is
nicely depicted you know here in the
flow cytometry you know plots
in this slide you observe a detailed
step-by-step getting a strategy in order
to evaluate dc abundance in blood
samples yeah so cells realized
you know cells from life's blood were
characterized using the panels shown
here in this table yeah first the debris
and then the seven a d positive dead
cells uh were excluded and then cd45
positive cells
you know cd45 positive cells were were
selected yeah so and from there
yeah so cytoskeleton lower cells were
selected
and yeah so the cd14 cd20 negative cells
were selected and within this abundance
of pdc you know expressing cd 123 and cd
303 were selected yeah as well as
you know
uh cd 141 expressing cdc
cdc1 was evaluated
yeah so and next
after excluding you know the cd 123
positive cells the abundance of cd cd c2
you know were assessed you know using
these
these markers so cdc2 is positive for
for these two markers
so you can find detailed standing
protocol you know under the link
provided here you know on our website
yeah
in the next slides i will talk about our
magnetic isolation solutions for
dendritic cells
in order to perform molecular analysis
of cells or you know to perform cell
culture experiments researchers need to
isolate you know the cells of interest
and so how do they do that yeah so
we have here our solution is the
magnetic cell separation so it's simple
cell isolation method yeah it enables
the preparation of high quality cells
you know suitable for downstream
applications such as dc and tc you know
t cell co-culture what they call you
know mlr mixed lymphocyte reaction or
some people call it mixed leukocyte
reaction so using this technology you
know reduces time required for flow
cytometric analysis
or uh sorting rare
you know
cell subsets
so
as you observe here
yeah in the flow cytometry you know uh
analysis you know shown here at the
bottom
yeah so the abundance of resident and my
resident and migrating disease in mouse
lymph node cell suspension your we're
more than 60
fold enrichment you know of target cells
yeah
using you know our cd 11c you know
microbead ultra you know ultra pure
so and the uh
maxwell separation technology is
compatible with most laboratory
techniques and applications
the
cd11c microbeads ultra pure mentioned on
the previous slide were used to isolate
cd11c positive cells
from
spleen
lung lamina propria and tumor tissue
yeah so tissues were harvested and
dissociated using tissue-specific
dissociation kits and the gentle mass
dissociator
and the cell suspension was labeled
with cd11c microbeads ultra pure and
magnetically separated yeah so followed
by flow statometric analysis to compare
the abundance
of dendritic cells subsets in the
starting material and in the enriched
fraction
yeah and in the
so the bottom panel beautifully shows
10
you know to
40 42 fold
enrichment of dendritic cells in the
tissues
you know tested
we have many products and solutions for
optimal enrichment of mouse disease
yeah for more information please visit
our website or contact your you know
local
you know local team you know
sales representative to find the
products that are tailored to your your
needs
in this slide you observe an
an example of enrichment of human cross
presenting cd 141 disease yeah
so sela isolated you know the cells
isolate this is isolated with cd 100 for
one micro bit kids are highly enriched
you know they express typical cdc one
surface markers such as cd 141
hdr and co
yeah this these cells are fully
functional upon stimulation with glr
tlr3 agonistia such as poly ic
they're able to express you know
upregulate expression of activation
markers cd80 cd68 and core these cells
are also able to secrete typical
cytokines yes gm gm csf
yeah interferon gamma and alpha gnf tnf
alpha and and other various uh
interleukins as you observe here
we also have many solutions for
isolating
human disease
yeah as mentioned before you can visit
our website or contact your local sales
representative you know to find more our
you know
more about our dc's you know human dc
products tell it to you
your needs
now let's talk about more dc generation
as the name says it you know
monocyte drive dc is monocyte drive dc
so the generation of monocyte drive
disease begins with the isolation of
monocytes yeah
so the solutions presented here are
developed to facilitate the isolation of
total so they call it also pan
monoscience yeah
so cd14 positive
classical monocytes cd-14 positive
classical monocytes and cd 16 positive
cd14 negative non-classical monocytes
yeah
however
for
more dc generation researchers use
either the cd14 classical monocytes or
pan monocytes isolation yeah so the cd40
micro bits are the most commonly
mentioned unsighted solution you know
for the generation of more dc
as highlight product let me introduce
you our straight from solution for
monocyte isolation yeah so a straight
from technology enables the separation
of highly pure
cells you know directly from different
you know blood sources with all
the benefits of the max microbial as
well as easy and fast enrichment of
leukocytes so no need for density
gradient no cell counting no washing and
no erythrocyte lysis needed so is
you know the efficient
solution for monocyte isolation
we can support you with the complete
workflow for more dc generation
so one of the key elements you know one
of the success key elements for that is
the standardized culture using max
premium grade cytokines yeah so to
optimally differentiate and match your
mode you see you know we know the exact
unit per milligram dosing which allows
high reproducibility so this data yeah
show the functionality of more dc
differentiated and matured using you
know our cell culture solutions yeah
these cells are able to increase the
expression of activation markers during
maturation they are able to migrate in a
you know trans well migration assay and
they are able to you know to secrete
cytokines so such as il-12 and il-10
upon stimulation with you know ligands
such as cd40 cd40 ligands
yeah
so
and you find the detailed protocols here
about more dc generation and additional
details for downstream applications you
know in this in this link yeah so
in our website
in the next two slides i would like to
tease you a little bit
with our special biology platform you
know which allows you to characterize
dendritic cells and gain special
information about these cells
for special analysis is the maximum
imaging system
which is part of a complete imaging
platform yeah that enables you to
analyze hundreds of markers on a single
sample you know and in a fully automated
manner so it means
apart from loading the samples and the
reagents no manual steps are involved
after starting you know the experiment
so moreover all the necessary components
to perform such experiments will be
provided which are sample carriers
antibodies and also the analysis
software
so i would like to mention here that the
maxima imaging platform is an open
platform with regards to antibodies
which means that you are not dependent
on the antibodies miltoni biotech is
providing although we have a huge
portfolio of high quality
recombinantly engineered antibodies yeah
so we have the largest antibody
portfolio compared to all other
multiplexing technologies uh on the
market right now so the
this complete platform solution
therefore opens up such complex analysis
to a very broad spectrum
of users as the as the technical hurdles
are are really very low
so
it's also very flexible as it can handle
any kind of fixed samples you know such
as tissues adherent cells or suspension
cells
and the preparation of the sample does
not require laborious and complicated
steps which means effortless experiment
preparation
in this experiment the tumor immune
micro environment particularly the
tertiary lymphoid
of ovarian cancer tissue was
investigated using the maximum here you
observe an overlay of seven markers
yeah characterizing the tumor cells in
green
and various immune cells you know such
as b cells and violet t cells in blue
plasma cell sustain with cd 138
in white
yeah uh then predict cells you know s10
with cd68 uh with cd86
in
in brown
yeah and myeloid cells
stand with cd14
in yellow and endothelial cells you know
extend with you know mech mech a 79 yeah
so thanks to the you know maximum
uh platform you know for analyzing you
know these several markers in the tumor
immune micro environment
our goal is to support your dc research
from a to z
so from sample preparation to cell
separation to flow analysis to cell
culture as well as dc characterization
using our spatial biology imaging
technology we have available material
online such as protocols and application
notes that can support your dc research
please feel free to visit multibiotech
website and check that or contact your
local sales for further support
this is my disclaimer
thank you very much for your attention
now if you have any question please
submit it and i would be happy to to
answer it
thank you dr youssef for your time today
and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor miltoni biotek for
underwriting today's educational webcast
questions will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event
until next time goodbye
you